Jeff so much of this story and so much
of the book that you wrote is about how
uncomfortable you are with the idea that
you get all this attention from what
happened so when a filmmaker comes to
you and says you know you've written the
story you've had the media coverage but
we're gonna do one more thing we're
gonna make a movie about your life what
is the level of willingness or
unwillingness to go one more step in
terms of telling the story well at that
point in my life I was I think when I
talked to you I was heading to the
casino with Sully and Big D and we were
feeling good and how was a drunk yes
yeah so I you know I thought it was a
joke I was you know I was like all right
cool movie you know I love movies that's
what I was thinking and then as I was
starting the process and I got the meets
odd and John I realized you know it
might be something special
so I accepted that and then I then it
just got bigger and bigger and Dave
David Gordon Green signed on and I met
Dave and I was like oh he's he's the
real deal he's a it was kind of weird
but he's a nice guy and um just from
what he was talking about you know I
knew that he wanted to do a like a real
film about this and it was gonna be
honest and and real and that's how Davis
and then Jake signed on and and it was
just like wow this is really gonna
happen so I mean it was tough but you
know it was also you know cool because I
didn't know what was gonna come and I
loved movies so you know I was kind of
excited to see what this is gonna be
like John there's a there probably two
different versions of of this story that
you can see there's the film and then
there's the book and they're very
different things when you are thinking
about what it is that you want to tell
the story that you want to tell and the
true story that you want to tell what
are the conversations you have with Jeff
and his family about getting to that
story and how do you go about kind of
almost re reporting the story that's
already been told well you know I like a
lot of people I read the book it was
really it was really moving but it was
pretty evident that like there's a much
deeper story in there I mean he wrote it
pretty quick and he wrote
he was sort of hadn't even really
processed a lot so talking to Jeff and
going out there and I grew up you know
about 35 minutes from the neighborhood
so I kind of got it and I got a like
sort of the idea that people where we
grew up hide a lot you know keep a lot
contained takes a while to crack away at
that and so we just went out there and
it was it was not easy you know getting
the truth getting to the really really
uncomfortable places and in the pain and
I got to know Jeff for a long time and a
lot of his family and the story was
still happening while I got to know him
and you know I I just think I gained
everyone's trust and and they realized
that it was coming out of love and I've
sort of fell in love with everybody and
said to tell this story the right way we
have to really really go to dark places
and and not flinch away from that and
after a lot of time they started to open
up and really give me a lot and Jeff you
know I'd circle back and ask him and
he's like you know they told you that
yeah that did happen that kind of stuff
so yeah I mean it was a real it was a
long process it was it was I'm just glad
they gave me that kind of trust but it
definitely wasn't easy
Jake you come on as an actor and a
producer do they happen at the same time
does one to get the other what was your
how did you come out into the project
that's a producer I guess and is that
after you've signed on to play Jeff I
had initially signed on as as an actor
that was it and then one thing led to
another and a sort of strange circuitous
journey that is getting a movie made and
financing was sort of slipping and all
those ideas were happening and I just
started a my own company that had a
financing deal with bold films who are a
great company finance Nightcrawler film
that I was in and as things were
slipping I gave them the script and I
said hey would you guys be into this and
they said yeah and that's how I became a
producer on the project and then we were
you know making the movie all together
and then I was I was and then
yeah Todd why is David Gordon Green a
good choice as a direct for a story like
this because what John's just talking
about you've opened almost a Pandora's
box because you're having this
conversation as a screenwriter about
what heroism is and you have to make a
movie that embraces that but doesn't
take advantage of it so you're not
cashing in on the very idea that you're
trying to examine yeah I mean David
might have been an unconventional choice
but one that we were really excited
about because you know certainly going
back his earlier work like all the real
girls in George Washington he has a real
a real facility for reality and kind of
getting into humanity and character and
certainly this movie has that in spades
but then the other side of it and the
thing that you know John did so
brilliantly with the script and Jeff has
naturally as just a person is a sense of
humor and how do you kind of put the
release valve into those extremely
dramatic moments that we knew we were
gonna be having in the movie and David
also has a really steady hand at comedy
so the idea of someone who can kind of
thread the tone between those two felt
really important for this movie and he
came in and sat and kind of really just
got the script and embraced that whole
idea and because he's a guy who's done
so many different kinds of things in his
career tackling something brand-new for
him was a new idea so it was kind of a
risk on all of our parts but I think you
know both personality wise and and
tonally he was the right guy Jake I'm
gonna ask you something about playing
somebody like Jeff and the way in which
he is seen and the way in which that
reflects on what you do in your line of
work and I came across a quote from Tom
Hanks where he's talking about Sully and
I think it's a really good line here's
what Tom Hanks says there is this
projection that is put upon you as an
actor that because you played these guys
you actually have some of their
attributes believe me my skill set is to
make it appear as though I have these
attributes without having any of the
actual attributes that being said as an
audience guy as a guy who saw movies as
I was growing up the power of the cinema
and the power of the heroic vision the
guy you can rely on in motion pictures
makes you feel as though when you leave
the theater that you spent that time
very well and that you have some degree
of greater confidence that you belong to
something bigger than yourself and that
there are people that you can have faith
in amen
I mean I don't know I yeah yes I think
that there is a an enormous part of
performance and acting that is wish
fulfillment you know I think that when
you have the opportunity even to pick
the roles that you choose I think you
end up sort of trying sometimes that
unconsciously moving towards people you
you would like to be like in my case
that's not necessarily true most of the
time but I but but no I think you you
know the idea of physical strength is
something that I always want to explore
there was a lot of things you you wish
to explore and wish to think about
yourself and then there's Jeff and the
realization that no matter what I did or
no matter how hard I tried I don't think
that I would have probably been able to
survive I don't think that I would
probably able to have a strength that
this man has and having to play that
well somewhere knowing that is I think
actually Jeff's journey yeah and so that
was what I discovered along the way was
the idea that it is always the doubt it
is the thing in your mind saying I can't
do it that makes you ultimately if
you're still here do it and I see him at
like now you know we're even closer now
than when we were filming this past year
has been an extraordinary year for him a
year full of bigger growth and I've seen
any of my friends have he is 15 months
sober he is a father devoted to it yes
you only drink Pellegrino at the wedding
last night I know that for a fact right
yeah they didn't have any Pelley's oh
okay
no Seltzer's yeah just Seltzer and on
Pelle but I think the last 15 months to
become a father to really commit himself
to being a father to commit himself to
that life and you know I think that that
growth is extraordinary and so to me all
I can say is in those moments of doubt
those moments were which I have
constantly where I don't believe in
myself I always think of Jeff and
playing him was an honor because by
proxy I got to feel the extraordinary
love that has passed his way that helped
him survive and it has been truly the
greatest honor of my career and
definitely one of my life and that's
that
[Applause]